hello everyone happy Monday hey Ben hi
oh just badly doing I'm John Luke and
we're playing at Monster Hunter World
the beta available for ps4 yes for
and this is the last day of the beta
ends tomorrow at 9:00 in the morning so
we're going to check some out we were
playing the weekend yeah it's a real
good time of this game is really cool
I've played a couple of months to
hundreds in my time so I've done a
couple of months this is your first yeah
this is my first time playing which is I
like it a lot I think this game is a
really cool I'm gonna switch over here
so that I can play to us sure I'm your
cool alright guys in the chat I'm not
able to see you unfortunately by the way
everyone who is watching we have the
code up so I join whose wants to play
with us join in first first come first
serve first two people anyone who wants
to play we'll give it a couple minutes
just to curios no one else joins in
we'll just go by ourselves and play the
first one but then we'll try and maybe
open it back up again
yeah the the party is actually I've got
it set so for permanent spots so I'm
going with my my traditional scrub
classic longsword that I love so much
they added a really cool move with it in
this game really really into it I'm
gonna go to the bow I tried the bow out
it was a good time which if you played
monsters before
range weapons are actually super viable
it just turns into like a third person
shooter which is great yeah like you
have just a gun there's just just a gun
you're just shove an ammo in it and
you're shooting people it's awesome it's
I think that's the coolest thing is
every weapon feels really different
mm-hmm try that um like that two-handed
so they can't hear us we get real close
hello
I'm gonna bump up the volume there's
been volume issues yeah people come in
here messing with all the settings and
everything hey we're gonna talk way
louder all right guys so we're just
we're just waiting for some people to
potentially join if anyone in the chat
wants to join we have a code up a little
better
perfect all right a lot better awesome
it's our fault we strayed too far away
from you guys
apologies but we're back yeah
if you would like to join don't keep
another minute or two but we can't we
can't sit here too long people gotta get
get their their consoles up and all that
all of that
yeah yeah man so uh how as someone who
has never played master hunter before
what is the rest of the game like how
does the game actually work later oh so
you don't just go out to hunt monsters
for the sake of finding monsters it's
okay it's to turn them into pants oh
okay
so way better you you go out and you you
hunt them and you break parts off of
them and you basically use all of these
to construct your armor or your weapons
or upgrade them hmm
so the driving force behind everything
is like oh I want to get this set so I'm
gonna kill this thing a whole bunch of
times til I can make this set and then
you level it up or you move on to the
next one and it just makes it easier
okay I like that so there's there's that
apparently there's actually like a story
mode in this game which is kind of weird
throughout the game volume followed up a
little bit you might get kinda intense
you know we could probably actually do
this first hunt by ourselves you know
yeah let's just get right in there
watching stop this this first one is
kind of a joke and you guys can if you
want to kind of get prepared you can
join us the room code will pop up again
but yeah cool so I'll chat my phone so
we can take it again a little bit yeah
this this first monster is is kind of a
like I said it's kind of an easier one
it's a bit silly but
there they just got done like eating so
they're really slow in the dragging your
stomach on the ground and it kind of
helps play into this but you actually
track stuff that's cool as a concept
yeah cuz before you just kind of like
run around till you found them or you'd
like wave to the Flint or Zeppelin or
whatever and it wouldn't be like oh it's
over here explain what your character is
doing over there oh so a very important
part of every hunt of course is eating a
delicious meal to boost your stats to
have some really delicious
[Music]
yeah so the the phase for actually
finding it now is a lot different the of
these these flies that will actually oh
hello hello it's frozen oh my gosh thank
you tag will hold up we'll wait wait so
we can get this fixed hmm
Game Boy is frozen you may say I just
ate food and that's it delicious
delicious food it's frozen is definitely
frozen oh yeah even knows these are
typical typical things that
all sorts of hunters on their way to
fight great scary things it's frozen
okay we're working we've got top top
people we're working on it fixing it
right now we're good we're good awesome
all right we're in it's back three so I
brought everyone so we can I'll do it
again let's just uh let's just hang out
Oh
if we ever hang out with IGN people oh I
was just about to say if anyone wants to
go into the IGN chat and just gets held
James and he's a scrub do it for me
yeah Ben Easter Easter I actually I used
to work for him and he's a really cool
guy and I don't know that I'm joking
around
I thought it'd actually be kind of cool
with me we like yeah we've got two spots
we teamed up with them would be kind of
neat but jump in what's up oh I
apologize I did not okay well John who
does his stuff I'm going to start on our
tracking it's okay first thing was not
my fault
we we did our game of the year and
everything's just been kind of hanging
out ever since I hate mondays am i right
Monster Hunter Mondays Mondays that's a
good name it's alliteration we've got it
be be on the lookout for Monster Hunter
Mondays probably not yeah don't get
their hopes up man the IGN office is
literally like a couple of blocks away
like we could do like a kind of like a
cool hangout rundown okay so we're in
our tracking phase right now we're
hanging out you find out the dude I'm
just kind of running to where I kind of
like pops up in the same place all the
time in demo but you find like four
things like I just you can tell that
people are wondering about the beta is
free yes do you have to have PSN ps+ yes
yes plus so if you own PS plus it is
free anything about I feel like a pc
beta might be a good thing to them but
the PC release is actually a little bit
later than the actual release well shoot
a rock at him just to make him angry
I it's given me always tutorials again
yeah that's the thing kind of like there
we go jump on its back this is yeah do
it you can actually like run on the
different parts of them and attack his
head instead of
who's like my favorite be out of this
and like Monster Hunter one of the more
reason it's okay there's just a kid see
you're kind of here it's fine so if you
if you spend your future regular shot
with circle like three times you'll do
like a thing where you just like oh yeah
it's messing with it earlier today oh I
wonder when this comes out comes on
January 26 yes it's right around the
corner
I do think comes up the same day as like
Dragon Ball oh really
yeah that's uh that's going to Titan
think I think I think Oh Dragon Ball for
Cindy there we go
[Music]
Oh God
yeah but just tossing it around like a
rag doll which is uh not scripted like
that was dumb cuz the second time I
fought him he wasn't doing that at all
like I like it was it felt so like
cinematic yeah I mean just I'm like oh
wow like that's a cool thing they see
the the second guy almost every time I
fought the second guy it's always gotta
go back to war
so like the spot where the weird like
aquatic alligator type of thing comes
out but when we were fighting him like
it went underground then came up and
then like landed on top of the guy it
was really crazy if it's frozen for you
you can try changing the the resolution
or maybe refreshing so we could play
monster for you maybe try hitting f5 I
played a fair amount of monster for mana
for ultimate there's a good time
I don't really start getting in a
monster hunter until like three okay try
which one yeah that was on the Wii right
yeah yeah which had underwater parts
we just eat something so it's get up in
there jump off so for anyone watching if
you want play we still have to saw so
pens yeah wait'll we'll give another
minute see if anyone wants to jump in
and put in that code start up join in
come and carry us through these as
monster hunts well so this is a part
that that I don't know if you know about
you haven't had was really the
ceremonious gathering of your booth he
runs so much better on the pro yeah I'm
playing on the pro here it lets you
quickly frame rate as option
good John Madden we got your target
destroyer he's got the only award and
killed it doing it yeah that's a good
kind of like intro level we have three
different monsters you can hunt and
they're all at three different levels
the next one a little bit bigger a
little more challenging he's got some
weird like effects that he has where he
like throws mud all over the place he's
older oh yeah once you show off
something else so the other weapon I use
a lot was the switch X so I'll use that
I'm not like super good with it but I
like it a lot nice oh yeah so we're
first camp second hunts that is our
quest ID if you'd like to join we'll
wait a little bit for you to kind of
come in if you're not monitoring the
YouTube chat apologies to people on
Twitch I can't have both open on my
phone the shadow tell you people
watching on twitch you're a good bunch
some good deeds same ellington we are
playing this on the ps4 it is a free
open beta for those with PlayStation
Network or PlayStation Plus yeah that PS
Plus technology yeah how is everyone
doing how how was your your Monday going
my money's going okay you're doing
pretty well now it's gone okay nice I'm
I'm kind of having a good time I didn't
expect to play Monster Hunter on a
stream today so I'm doing
and real Stokes always a good time yeah
so the the cat's the pelicans
calicos that's what the Carlton yeah
what did how crazy can you get with them
as far as like customization so
apparently the customization in this
game is just really really good but they
don't have it in the beta it's all
preset stuff okay yeah but before you
could like customize facial features
like I was able to make like a big boss
cat was like is I missing
[Music]
I got this really cute calico looking
dude right now
hey we got a dude we did it we're doing
it oh cool we got someone and maybe
we'll get a fourth we'll give it another
minute
yeah good time three though we can
definitely oh yeah we can take this on
the game just scale though right
depending on I think a dump so I know
there were separate progressions and
most of the other monsters like the the
story that's not really a story and then
there's also like getting a multiplayer
and getting like G ranks and okay and
all that stuff is there a reason why I
would want to play this by myself
you have something to prove okay and you
can't convince your friends to farm the
same thing you want to farm to get the
pair of pants that you want valid but
yeah it's it's still a pretty good game
to play by yourself it's just a lot more
fun with your friends but if like oh god
I'm on its back don't ya don't hit me
dang it's like am i limited in my
experience if I play by myself I don't
think you need okay just just miss out
on having a good time good time with
your friends
yeah all right Dizzy's want to want to
give it a go yeah why don't you pop in
here with this guy all right I'm gonna
I'm gonna say apologies if anyone's like
typing in that code
if you want to you can remember it and
then we can pick you up for the last one
and not the last one because I'm sure
we're gonna go back and do the Hunts
again at some point you're not gonna go
straight through yeah yeah yeah got a 10
second timer left
I feel bad if devious is still trying to
set up the gear I hope not oh there we
go whoo all right all right I'm sorry
didn't stick anyone with the thing they
didn't want to do but yeah Nikko Games
forces hello hello sir hello thanks for
joining us for Monster Hunter Monday
monster Monday here on new spot.com
Monday not Mondays if I say Mondays it
implies we're gonna do this again
Yeah right I cannot promise that
[Music]
[Music]
chefs choice again demon souls Friday
like you know just mix it up every day
we'll do something God look at how good
that final fantasy 15 level of quality
food I wonder so the other thing that
recently with the last couple games
actually do specific missions much about
this game because I've been wanting to
kind of keep myself in the dark yeah I
know I know very little about it which
is kind of cool because I feel like I'm
just learning I'm being surprised by it
yeah no one's asking where we got the
tetris shelf in the back actually don't
know it's been here for a while it's
pretty cool it's pretty cool I even
realized it was a Tetris show I just I
just thought it was a really cool
looking like thing you got from Mike
here somehow I see it that's that's
completely on-brand all right Steve
seems to be going somewhere I'm Gor on
my way you guys are going on your way I
think I know where we're gonna run into
them
just because I've done this a couple of
times
I'm totally skipping over the the proper
track on procedure that's okay someone's
asking if this will be on PC yes it will
yeah do you see just not not right away
right away which means I'll probably end
up being useful with my place of choice
you found him there's our boy there is
all I'm gonna I'm gonna do a thing I'm
gonna head them off at the pass
put on my cloak so yeah they have cloaks
now which is kind of cool but this one
lets you kind of like glide so if I time
this do it do it got him right there see
that
now we're monster hunting oh god he's
gonna set my dude please bringing him to
bring him you oh he hit his head on the
wall he's real upset now
almost there just a little bit more
Oh
[Music]
Oh
yeah there's a couple that do that like
a
very like Oh
down for transforming swords
[Music]
[Music]
he's running away what's what's our so I
think that's a hunting horn so he's
given us while you swing the weapon it
basically plays notes it's basically a
musical instrument
oh he's giving us like buffs yes and
then with each different swing you can
do a different combination to give you
different buffs when you like finish the
combo you press a button to play it it's
it's kind of cool like a nice little
like a bard kind of support
but it's also like a giant hammer yeah
imagine an accordion I don't know if I
can like top
that's pretty good eisah brilliant
what's down
I hit you up here I'm so sorry
oh yeah better one staff
I'm gonna do that
is there bug stuff is a personal favor
just because I thought it was the
dumbest thing of the first night
[Music]
also the quick menu
it's very it's very menu system
[Music]
today the best experience because the
scheme feels like it's hurts
we got his tail yeah
why don't you change like so
see he's gotta try to Lenny it's
actually marked on the mattresses
Oh
come in
so I just a trailer that is actually
[Music]
oh that just passes tail oh man fine
wait a minute hold on get that slide
that's slide slide tech slide tech come
on oh I got on him save ya
guys have on his weight loading game
game volume just saying I can lower that
we can change that up okay I think he's
pretending to be dead yeah okay
all right I may get another run at this
[Music]
there we go get get those sword swings
yeah all right right up in there oh okay
you ran away he's really hurting though
come on Mason this game is for the
PlayStation 4 Xbox one and PC although
the PC version it's gonna come out a
little bit later and the fader we're
playing here is just for yes we did it
he didn't even make it to the weird like
bog lake at all no those those real good
rules we got to the bog lake and there
was like another monster that started
attacking him yeah yeah alright so I'm
gonna go hopefully that dude knows to uh
hit the button to stay in our party
otherwise you might get booted yeah if
you guys want to join get ready to to
see the code and and jump in come and
play with us where you'll fight a t-rex
in the middle of jungle I'm gonna use a
bug Lance it's gonna be a real real
happy time just killing it would you
like these freeze frames and the awards
kind of at the end to say that rodeo
champ I'm into it you think that like
has any tangible benefits outside just
feeling good I think it's a feel-good
thing which I'm totally okay yeah give
everyone a little bit of recognition for
what they do
alright the ancient forest menace we
have someone in the chat claiming to be
a monster hunter veteran do time zones
if anyone has any Monster Hunter
questions feel free to add him see
that's that's the real good thing to
like with the barrier of entry for
Monster Hunter being like is kind of
high as it is it's got a really really
good community and people are totally
down to like help you out that's nice
there we go bug Lance time
looking real good all right
I'd say other guys in serene try and get
one more person in we're just gonna give
another minute here see if anyone wants
to join yeah yeah oh man I like this
game a lot it's very good I was not
expecting to like it as much as I am I'm
really it makes me really excited
whenever like someone new gets into
monster honor cuz it just means I have
more people to talk to to about monster
honor I don't think I'm gonna be able to
get into it I mean that's just not the
way I play games work yeah I think
people treat monster nerd the same way
some people treat like destiny where
it's like this is my game it's all I
play mm-hmm it's just not how I play
games but the idea of like you know like
good get this game get a bunch of
friends it's kind of get on like on a
Friday night a couple of drinks and just
yes get some some real new pants some
really nice pants
this sounds really nice I'm it's a very
sincere that sounds really nice so what
so many monsters are on the base game no
idea are there usually I say it depends
there also
we heard just this morning if they're
planning to add extra monsters as free
DLC yeah even if you're not happy with
the final roster of monsters that I
think people are still trying to lock
down there will be more had these games
ever done much in the way of like DLC
content
yeah actually at least on the the 3s
ones that I've played oh really they put
out like special quests there's like
arena quest you can do where it's like
fight two of these monsters at the same
time or they'll put out special quests
for special like like gear like there
was one fer I think it was for ultimate
where he'd get like a Drive jacket if he
finished it mm-hmm which was totally not
not worth it but it was a good time
cool yeah someone saying unconfirmed
that there might be subspecies are
downloadable monster event hunts feature
he's saying it's unconfirmed but that's
kind of people are speculating exciting
either that's that's cool well people
are talking about the Mega Man outfit
yeah
I want that a loyal feel we had a lot of
really cool just all sorts of like
Nintendo ones to like there was a ask in
for one of the guns that changed it to
like samus's remember that you could
have the whole like it was a various
suit yeah I know people say it sometimes
I just area Vario yeah it's technically
not a real word but that's you know
that's alright
so think I think we should else is
joining let's just go I'm gonna hit that
that go button
yeah so I really like jumping on top of
the on top of the monsters and I like
doing that kind of fun time so that's
why I kind of got into the bug Lance cuz
it has a vault button so you can just
jump any time you want on top of it has
a lot of moves there's a complicated
weapon I don't even know what the bug
thing does so the way that the book
stuff works is from from my
understanding and someone probably might
know a little bit more because I'm just
not 100% up on it but you send the bug
out to extract stuff from different
parts of the monster and you can get
three different kinds and if you stack
it up you actually go into like a weird
berserk mode that lets you just do more
damage and be really crazy flourishing
with it what I I'm gonna fond of the
chef's choice again Oh timed perfectly
I'm gonna hit the veggie platter just
cuz that's not that's not vegetables my
screen leg is the exact same as yours
that that's uh okay I gotta admit I'm a
little disappointed I hit the veggie
platter just cuz I wanted to see what it
looked like my character is very clearly
eating a thing of meat right everyone's
everyone's eating they're all good I
gotta say that disappoints me yeah yeah
I think the food might have been
different another ones I was looking for
it for my character to like take a bite
of like I care it with the same amount
of - oh yeah that'd be really great and
we're going after the big guy right yeah
yeah big big t-rex dude
all right let's do it so they can show
up in a lot of places but they're in the
feeling like the thicker part of the
jungle from what I remember oh we've
already got footprints to track barovik
look saggy he headed off this way
possibly no not down that way yeah this
is kind of the edge of that's we're on
the edge of the map here I'm just gonna
run to where I I think I I think he'll
be okay that usually works out yeah well
well well maybe we'll find some
footprints along the way and that's what
matters is that typically a big part of
the game is just tracking him so like
before it was more of just like a run to
wherever they're supposed to be mm-hmm
which is why I think I kind of default
on to that but it's I think it's a
bigger thing in this one so you have the
the footprints and and all that old
footprints more Raptors get out of here
there's like a weird like a weird
through way up here that I think he kind
of Pat's around in so I ended up finding
him I think it's up this way
because the last time I was here he came
through people in the chat wondering
about the beta yeah it is open to the
public if you have PlayStation Plus and
it's open until tomorrow at 9:00 a.m.
Pacific time
so yeah you download out there that is
or is that someone else
oh that's uh that's not our boy but so
that's a that's Rathalos we found him so
that's a thing what's that is that like
a extra monster so that's that's an
extra monster it's kind of one that is I
don't want to say like like a flagship
kind of deal but it's it's one that
isn't a lot of games and it's very
recognizable oh I see I see
where are we going after amber scale uh
I don't know if we should we have a
limited time it's true I have no idea
where this this t-rex boy might be at
ooh
Melvin Irons just says he told James
he's a scrub nice perfect I'm waiting
for him to fire back gotta make sure to
say that Ben but Ben that's very
important don't don't put me in this I
don't want any part of that
I don't what these flashy things I just
following you dude I grabbed whoa I was
really cool I'm into it where where is
this where is this boy I'm gonna just
slide down here the sliding is kind of
my favorite thing I was watching a video
we're like one of the monsters like
broco a waterfall yeah like a dam and
and just all this water came rushing and
like knocked the player-character off
and that look cool like these dynamic
encounters we're just like they can do
stuff like that things like showing up
and seems really really cool more
footprints more footprints so it it's
saying this way ha or it looked like it
was pointing this way yeah I haven't
found another footprint though and he
would definitely not fit inside of there
so maybe we just go backwards maybe we
track it track it backwards
you know those monsters are pretty
clever sometimes it's true that rathalos
is flying above us it's I see it on the
map she she's like hey you should have
found it by now what are you what are
you doing you dummy
oh wait to read we find enough for the
trail I think we might have cuz I keep
walking backwards and I keep finding
footprints yeah oh hello there's a some
mucus on the wall here it's gonna scrape
that up track that mucus down got it
thank you you found found him got a
trail oh nice I think I think I found
true probably not I'm just gonna go to
you well it's leading me back to the
place you were well here this this will
work out then you just keep keep on that
trail it brought me right here this is
this is not who we're looking for these
are small boys well watch our friend is
probably off actually fighting them or
something it would tell us wouldn't it I
think so I'm gonna head down this way
uh did he land I heard music kick up cuz
I think he's fighting that that other
dude uh scrub man we don't got time
let's just fight this guy our boy is
boys in trouble we gotta go album can I
climb got climb up it's really weird cuz
like he usually pops up by now found
more old footprints I wonder I think
he's up higher the trails telling me to
go this way
you you actually have a trail so that's
I'm gonna go I have a trail to oh there
is I found him
oh nice hey just like that just like we
planned the whole time yeah yeah what's
up here he is grab that footprint real
quick okay oh now I'm stuck in the tree
go call him back
go for the tail that's the same one
there we go
where you going come back hey there
buddy
don't go anywhere Seoul sorts of jumping
around I'm already on top of him yeah I
love the bug blade get ready okay
get that the slasher flurry yeah perfect
whoa I get I think that's the last one I
need yeah it is
oh come on I was way over you
Oh got some melodies
that's the stuff buffs attack up health
up also in saying we should lead him to
wrap wrap wrap towels
yes wrap towel I don't know it but I'm
like half looking at the screen and it's
okay we actually that's not a bad thing
because that's that's like uh it's like
a strategy like a proper strategy oh man
so I think that they'd probably be up at
the top I'm just gonna jump on him again
I guess right now whoa hi I threw myself
off
back the tail I totally missed it its
heat I think we literally beat the poop
out of him so weird thing that is how
wrong I as I was leaving I stumbled into
a pile of of excrement that was kind of
kind of large you still got the dumb die
on now I'm gonna need a heal which seems
my health is dropping get him some of
that life powder
oh you got it you're good I'm good I'm
good
whoa jeez a tree fell on me excuse me
I'm just gonna don't like just trying to
sharpen my blade oh yeah
oh the sun's starting to set just
getting getting real pretty in here
movies not letting me do my thing
Oh No did he he's eating you not not
today don't don't eat John Luke get out
of there
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna use a whetstone
really there we go okay all right okay
you're good you're out it's real nice to
him to let you go
so yeah geez this guy I need to get that
oh geez he'd get and he'd get a shot on
his head
just like that perfect this guy he's
giving me some trouble yeah right ahead
a lot of flipping that I didn't really
do much of anything
here we go get that that redirection
midair and get on his tail he got his
tail I mean I'm gonna get on his head
jeez what are you doing what happened
there he is jumping get away from there
get back up in the front come on that
flurry yeah
all that back up there she's running
away don't do it
come back it looks like he's kind of
running higher up though which could be
a bad thing
oh man I don't know if we'll do this in
time because the tickets a really long
time to find him okay well we'll finish
this and if we don't finish it it's
about to be a heck of a time Oh God
right ahead perfect okay
don't yell at me
no I think did it's okay
now just get carted off and then you you
come back I think yeah just got you just
gotta run it back
okay well thankfully that camps actually
incredibly close to where we are as nice
now immediately get it come on
get it oh my gosh I'm so close every
time it's running through trees it's not
a fire whoa
someone's got some really cool effects
going on here there's some some
paralysis happening to him nice nice I
have to sharpen up again
come on
I was targeting onto his head the whole
time that's why everything was acting so
weird
perfect
all right head
come on get back up there
there we go there we go yep
now he's not dead he's taking a nap
I get that maybe this guy isn't so bad
I feel a man maybe maybe we shouldn't be
fighting this dude maybe we should just
just all take take a nap where'd he go
you ran over over this way she's getting
out of here so this is a lame nap spot I
needed to find someplace better so says
the screen is frozen oh no it is ah man
it's okay we can we can fix it okay we
can fix it I remember what a day
hopefully it hasn't it hasn't been
frozen too long no I don't think it
froze a while ago oh geez
so imagine if you will me doing a whole
bunch of dumb flipping and missing the
dinosaur a lot and that's pretty
accurate too what's what's been
happening yeah well we'll have this
sorted out here in just a second just
getting a lot of a lot of just
play-by-play can't even imagine okay
that's real difficult for me to do it's
gonna sit here I'll give like a like a
an audio play-by-play like the dinosaurs
shooting fire out everywhere he's got
his wings out he's looking real angry
not gonna be good
but devious is is doing work here by
themselves I should probably jump in and
help them woof
screen still frozen yeah well we'll have
it we'll have it back up here in a
second everything will be a-okay it's
okay
Eric's back he'll he'll do it right
[Music]
is back we did it okay here we are
hanging out with our t-rex pal how's
that going oh you know it's going my
screen my audio is just quiet it's just
very quiet nothing happening great oh
yeah it could have been better
let's be honest but I appreciate your
willingness to play along I tried to
should try to paint more vivid images
with my my mouth words but he's he's
stumbling okay I'm gonna try and pop
back in try to try get back in well
we're in the we're in the messy swamp
right now oh yeah you can't stop a
far-away okay you were you're trying to
fix the the technical issues the real
monster the real monster all along was
the technical we just got to redo this
one then cuz that people couldn't see
like any so I think actually we've been
having enough technical issues that I
will hold off playing oh okay this
monitor or make sure things good if this
happens again so that good experience
for the stream so if you want to just do
do that hunt maybe we can get one more
person in here yeah I will will leave
the room number up so if you guys want
to join and you can it'll be a good time
oh man there it is on sale Friday
it's a Friday release oh really that's
kind of yeah alright I'm going to change
everybody sorry about all the technical
issues we've been having today I don't
know what's up with that that's that's a
new one yeah I'll do you know I'm gonna
do the boat we're let's see how how
range is different
Oh gun kutzle two gun guns are cool
bootable I was really digging the bow so
that's that's women uh yeah the bow if
you hit the evade button it'll like it
kind of like this timer where you can do
like a bonus damage shot I like it feel
like time it that that was pretty cool
tech support is is definitely needed cuz
we got it now
alright cool that full-time tech support
full-time tech support right here yeah
so if you want to join its the third the
third monster the first camp and that is
the quest ID will give you a little
while to get in yeah and we can go
murder this thing proper yeah he was
hurt a lot you you could see it whoa
that's that'd be an interesting
challenge to try and do I haven't even I
don't like trapping them which is kind
of sad I feel like the spirit of Monster
Hunter like getting in and doing the hey
we got another person there we go
see three is good that's good we give
and we can get one more can we get a
full hunting party going that's what we
need to know man and we did it I'm gonna
I'm gonna let you guys have some time to
get ready and then I'll I'll tell you
I'll give you like like like a minute
why don't you show off the different
gear like the different armor so they
give you a couple of sets this kind of
like woodland kind of like hood I like
that one it's kind of cool I like the
first one a lot the first one is pretty
cool I like this one a lot though just
cuz it it reminds me a lot of I don't
remember the name of the set but it's
one that I used a lot in one of the
older ones go for like a full suit of
armor kind of look if you're feeling it
some more more grassy type stuff it's
still pretty good
yeah it's there isn't much in the demo
that the offer but I'm wondering if
these are the sets they give you for
finishing all of the all the hunts
because you you get face paint for
finish
one of them and I think you get a couple
of sets just to use right off the bat if
you finish all of them but it might be
them so I'm gonna sit gonna say we're
ready to go yeah I've got that 30-second
countdown most of us are ready to go
devious you're you've been rockin with
us the whole time you're already set I
don't even need to worry about you
killing it yes this is it we're gonna
put this this dinosaur this ancient
menace in the ground and then we're
going to use all of their parts to make
pants it'll be a good time
wonderful dang alright so I got I gotta
ask you you you cure yourself at being
able to watch this in case it falls
apart again mm-hmm are you okay are you
okay with that are you are you kind of
wishing you're still playing I mean I
was having a really good time so I this
weekend I realized that I had not played
Master Hunter in a long time and playing
this this beta kind of got me really
excited for it and I kinda just want to
be playing it all the time
and it's one of those things I'm
thinking about a lot yeah delicious meat
ready to go all right is everyone
already out they're all eating some of
them ready eating some of them just left
guys can can make sure you get your your
food inside yeah I'm gonna start looking
around for for tracks hopefully we can
find this guy found some stuff over here
anything going on I'm just gonna head in
into the forest area cuz I feel like
that's where he pops up all the time do
you feel like it is just several
different set locations that's kind of
how it was before where it's like oh
this monster almost is always in zone 8
and you know to always find them kind of
in that area so it's still kind of
similar it feels yeah which is good
well I feel like this guy has a very big
area that he Pat's around in so it kind
of kind of makes a little bit a little
bit random not too bad though giga spud
excellent name in the chats as hi guys
hello hello how's it going it's good to
see you I hope you're having a good day
there's got to be some footprints here
because this is where we saw him before
and this is where I run into him
Fairmount something to track off of aha
we've got footprints and we've got gunk
on the wall so I was asking about
working you can get the open beta if you
have PlayStation a PlayStation Plus you
can go get it on the ps4 store I'm
trying to remember where I found it
exactly I think you can find in the demo
section in the demo section yeah the
PlayStation Store can sometimes be a
pain to navigate I've had issues where
like I'll search for something and it
doesn't pop up in the search but it's
totally there see it's a thing it just
doesn't pop up on the search so try the
try the betas I think there's like a
section called free and then you go
there and there's like betas so try that
out heart beat is a demos maybe try
there hopefully you can find it I don't
know what I'm tracking but I'm oh hello
footprints so what's this too loud too
loud now I'm sorry I didn't mean to
please accept my apology is that him
behind me no let's just I know why you
pointed my camera that way
are there like proper towns in this game
so there are in the other ones which is
why I'm people people might have found
him there are in the other games like
the actual like getting your Lobby
together with your friends you all kind
of hang out in one of them okay which is
why I'm kind of like I'm kind of
confused about the whole having to put
in an ID number thing mm-hmm
oh oh oh yeah I don't know why the Flies
wanted to show me this but it's really
cool I'm into it yeah man they're like
look check it out alright I'm on my way
over to manatees cuz it looks like
you're fighting yeah I think they found
in I'm very certain you found him I went
like some weird way backwards way I
trusted the flies and I was wrong for it
there he is there's our boy they are in
battle oh no iron sports pinned down I
know what the foam is there we go
paralyze coatings pretty good one him in
the mouth yeah yeah
come back
okay didn't really mean it services are
getting Rayman vibes not sure I follow
but uh do didn't you know every game is
secretly just Rayman that's that's the
facts I know I'm getting more of a gex
500 don't sleep my dude are you okay oh
I didn't even put the paralysis coating
on that would probably explain it so if
you if you after you attack yeah if you
do that you like charge it up yeah you
get the red seems to kind of want to
like shoot on its own so I really kind
of do that might just be me
oh you went right for you so don't I
don't do range weapons very often but I
[Music]
like this isn't bad
I'm kind of into it I'm definitely
fumbling around in it though so in the
chest coming there are 46 monsters in
this game but then other people are
saying no
so there's I'm gonna say there is a
amount of monsters I I like that number
there's at least three it's a very good
number to enter to go up this way that's
what it's telling me oh he's right there
yeah I get them in the butt
I'm using that that close for your stuff
down
nostalgia wants to know are there traps
in this game I imagine so
oh there are I just haven't been using
them very much they actually give you a
lot in the beta dnews
yeah the beta just seems to throw a lot
of resources that you to kind of mess
around with yeah we've got fishing net
that'll work
paralysis knife shock trap oh I didn't
mean to eat the steak to celebrate
looking in the menus shock traps we've
got barrel bombs oh well I'm gonna have
a barrel bomb out so the next time he's
down put one down whoa goodness someone
says this looks boring is it boring no
it's very fun to play actually if you
think this is boring I'm kind of
concerns but you know again Monster
Hunter isn't a thing for everyone that's
true
I totally understand there are things
about Monster Hunter that kind of scared
me away yeah hearing people talk about
it I don't know like I had a lot of fun
with this and either this is just like
all that other stuff is still in here
and you know maybe this is just fun
enough that I can kind of like get with
those or hopefully they actually fix you
know streamline some stuff I feel like
it's gonna be appreciated I think this
is a pretty good setup
Macari in the chat says hey I didn't
know you guys were streaming this game
right it's a crazy time place the
Monster Hunter dude it's a big fan the
series awesome nice I I'm I'm a fan as
well
started playing oh hey look I was back
he's just wait for me I want to hang out
to destroy that tree out here
he's having a rough time of it
everyone's climbing yeah
can I actually mount is that like is
that possible I don't know what would
you do I don't
oh she just kind of like stabbed with
your earring all right Wow also that is
a yeah right so this does aim for his
toes well I haven't done one of these
yet that's very
I like it a lot
these power shots are definitely the
thing
hello for asks what different range
weapons gonna use so that the beta here
they have to bow then they have to come
but they're like guns yeah there's a
along with the longer sniper gun type of
setup there is like a smaller
short-range one that you can actually
put down with traps with oh that's cool
so yeah maybe maybe shoot with toes is a
better idea
did that similar kind of leg down a
little bit
I always try to like aim for the head
though I'm kind of like there someone to
ask when's Boston honey universe
what if they combine fantasy star
monster huh I'd love to have a fantasy
star game come out in the West again
number one fantasy star - was gonna come
out here and they like recently deleted
the website they promised they promised
and they'd never brought it he's not
getting knocked down someone asked
where's Joey
if you're a friend of Joey he from the
office he's a working hard on some some
good good content for our best of the
year stuff which by the way we were
doing every day every day every day we
are counting down our top ten games at
ten o'clock
today we reveal their number ten it is
near automata or automata however you
pronounce Otto tomato Otto tomato
whatever you want it's yours it's a
great game well deserved so we got a
shock trap
I'll be yeah come back make sure to come
back every day at ten o'clock Pacific
time cuz that's where you'll reveal our
tennis maybe yeah
it could pop out at any time no no who
knows you'll have to be here to find out
and then that's when we take over the
stream with more monster honor pose
monster so I was asking about the deluxe
edition worth getting I'm not sure with
the dogs edition suburb answers Dragon
Ball Z journal vol fighter Z stream when
we can as soon as we can all the time
all of us are constantly real into that
one I you will does not you don't have
to search far in the office to find
someone who's excited for that game true
I think we're all incredibly stoked
about that you should come over this way
so I can shoot this barrel yeah like
that might need a heel o or no magatama
didn't have a chance so that means we've
got one more yeah they just knocked you
over one more fight oh yeah I'm totally
turned around that's the canteen
can I eat again yes I can I'm gonna just
asks how many hours do you need to kill
that thing if you actually give you I
think it's twenty or thirty minutes okay
we haven't gotten the 10-minute warning
heavily I don't think so
oh I can skip this I don't need to sit
here and watch it again it's probably
for the best escape that yeah yeah can I
actually slide underneath oh you just do
it automatic oh there are mines there he
is down there we made it so it's coming
at the deluxe edition apparently has a
ninja set oh that's pretty cool I'm into
that I'm very into that
oh you're out of all your other stuff
it's fine you only need close range
coating anyway now now someone's
claiming it was Samurai not a ninja
so samurais like samurais a little bit
more than ninjas so that that makes me
even more in apparently we did get the
10-minute warning Oh
so anyway we're running through here
trying to beat this guy less than ten
minutes my dude quit running he's going
way up to the top and I don't like that
he's just going for it
dude don't do this to me there are the
Rathalos is up there that's not what we
need at all don't jump don't apparently
there's an exclusive face paint you get
for the beta yeah you get a face paint
and I think you also get oh shoot oh you
guys already got the barrels in nice oh
so I totally botched that for everyone
but if that had actually been it
actually there's more barrels laid down
I'm not gonna shoot them I'm afraid to
shoot them everyone's around here but
this is the ideal time right you're
doing it I say do it you're doing it
sooner rather there we go that works
whoa no that does not work however
that's not what I need
my dude please
someone says get the Gjallarhorn dude
there you go that'll probably work oh
there we go
they seem to be all for like weird
collaboration skins having like a
destiny characters skin in this guy's it
makes more sense than anything probably
just put like board shacks in here or
something oh my God if shacks would do
the announcing for the Hunts once the
dinosaur guardian get him now it is what
someone who's not very good at
pretending to be shack space that was
perfect she nailed it
he's got that like semi worried kind of
weary sound that I really wish I could
just nail but can't quite do it yeah
it's like kind of look at the same
spirit of a Deckard Cain but on this old
yeah you know
oh oh no oh we lost the dude forwards
decreased six continued six continues it
used to be just three go Oh God your boy
just sidestepped off of the entire
planet here we are
I believe you then I I'm we're doing it
this is it we're gonna make it happen
just like that see count up the whole
time
didn't even doubt it for a second ah
this game looks sick
it is indeed sick highly recommend
trying it out I feel like this is a
great time for anyone who's been kind of
interested in Monster Hunter thinks this
looks kind of cool to jump in yeah
definitely try the bait out it still
goes until tomorrow so you've got time
yeah go check it out cool I think that's
probably were gonna call it yeah that's
that's a good you killed it by a giant
angry t-rex alright so I think everyone
for watching sorry about all the
technical issues that was kind of a bad
storm of hey let's play together it's
fine it's fine
but thank you for watching hopefully
we'll get a chance to check out more
Monster Hunter when it comes out it was
a January 26 right yeah about that and
then yes as I said before every day at
10 for this week and next week we're
gonna be counting down our top 10 games
of 2017 today we did number 10 which was
near automata and tomorrow we're going
to be doing number 9 so make sure to
tune in for that and all of you guys
have a wonderful day well I'll miss you
take it easy
you
[Music]